Shaquille O'Neal's son chérif is
honoring Kobe Bryant the 20 year old who
was close to Kobe and even called him
uncle showed the tattoos he got and
honored the NBA legend and his daughter
Gianna on his Instagram his new ink
features Gianna's number two jerseys she
wore for her mamba Academy team GG's a
basketball player she is that she's in
it does she have that inner focus like
her daddy yeah she's she's just don't go
killer out there yeah at both ends of
the floor and she plays defense as well
as offense when she competes with GG's
Jersey we can see an image of Kobe
holding a basketball with his hands in
the air as well as both of his jersey
numbers 8 and 24 Sharif also got a
tattoo reading Mamba mentality referring
to Kobe's lasting legacy of inspiring
others to constantly try to be the best
version of themselves our responsibility
is to always inspire and try to take
some of the life lessons that we have
learned and share those with the next
generation so that they can start their
journey with a lego Shareef previously
shared on Twitter that the Laker legend
had actually reached out to him on the
morning of his death Shareef tweeted
literally this morning you reached out
to me you've really been there for me
all 20 years of my life he also added
Gigi love you cousin fellow Lakers
LeBron James and Anthony Davis also got
tattoos paying tribute to the basketball
icon ET spoke to Sharif's dad last week
where shaq said he will do whatever
Kobe's kids need to heal you're gonna be
hurting for a long time they're just
gonna say
or to live in the internalize things
when people look at it you face they
picked me clear there was no air to
clear Big Brother little book will
forever be linked sake over you got to
say chef you say Shack you guys said
coke I just wish that he was here to see
it with us we we all good man
we will never let us never never never
never ever let him be forgotten was
already a martyr and kids kids kids kids
kids kids kids kids kids you will know
who the great Kobe Bryant was you got an
Italian those two little baby always
listen babies they don't call me uncle
Shaq for a reason you called me up when
you find me I'm not hard to find I do
whatever you are